once again
riffing with Griffin is back and we
doing it live
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to your favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to riffing with Griffin
doing it live got a late start just one
of those days but I'm here for you I'm
talking James Corden I'm talking bear
attacks
I'm talking Oscar Meyer made a popsicle
I'm talking Seahawks I'm talking house
of dragons and the NBA is back so let's
see what all we can talk about today
hopefully I get to it all
but you know how it is
[Music]
[Music]
yeah baby
[Music]
all right and we back and I should
probably Fade Out on that but welcome to
Griffin with Griffin episode 206 make
sure you subscribe share do all that
good stuff remember you know that's how
that works
um also you know you can find me on
Twitch I'll be on Twitch most days and
if you want to be you could be a twitch
member you could be a YouTube member or
you could even be a patreon member if
you just want to support the show in
some ways you know what I mean so that
is what it is and I appreciate you guys
for being here once again
on riffin with Griffin all right guys
now a word from our sponsor better help
uh easy and affordable online therapy
when you want to be a better Problem
Solver therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com
Griffin to get 10 off your first month
that's better h e l
p.com slash Griffin
all right guys what's up
how you doing
glad you guys are here chat welcome I
see you guys in there live you know hope
you got the notifications it is what it
is you know that's what happens when you
do stuff live uh you know sometimes and
I don't have really not necessarily a
set schedule because I do Tuesdays I got
like a busy day
uh you know did King King in the sting
today I think the name's Gonna Change uh
you know we got a new set so make sure
you go check that one out too also check
me out on gender gen with Matthew
Espinosa I thought that little you know
that's a little podcast that could you
know just two guys from different
Generations yep yapping about stuff so
make sure you check that out too and uh
also don't forget
um you know
um you know
patreon or like in my twitch I twitch a
lot too so make sure you uh check if you
like gaming and you know I interact so
make sure you check me out there
um first uh you know and I actually I
want to put this in the description
um
I went to skank Fest everybody
um
and I gotta tell you right now skank
Fest was it was so fun it was like more
than I would have even bargained for
yeah I need to write that in I wanted to
put that in this description live so you
guys can know what I'm talking about
um yeah man skank Fest was just I I I I
I can't
I can't say enough about skank Fest it
was in Vegas it was in downtown Vegas
at this place called notoriety this
complex that they just took over and it
was look shout out to Luis Gomez and Big
Jay oakerson
this
I mean
look
Lewis is a character man if you watch
him stream or if you know if you listen
to their podcast you know he's something
else man so I'm just going to be fully
transparent you know we had like a
little thing you know because
um I was on King of Sting at the time
and I'm like I was doing this joke where
I'm down playing uh my dates if you
watch Kingston you know I used to say
like three or four weeks in a row I'm
going to La Jolla guys you know I would
say it like that and so then I was like
doing the same thing like hey I'm going
to skank fast and I've said I don't even
know what I said something like I don't
know why I'm going to skank fast I said
something silly like that it was just an
offhanded comment and then I was on my
stream on Twitch and
um you know somebody came into the chat
and they were like hey Griff are you are
you going to skank Fest because you're
not on the website so then I was like oh
man I'm not on the website and then you
know it went and I offhandedly said
something like uh you know they're not
even paying a lot you know because I was
a little bit like hey [ __ ] I'm not on
how come I'm not on the side because I
want people to know I'm there whatever
it was it was like it was a nothing to
me nothing but you know you're live a
lot of people watch King of the sting
people are watching me live and then you
know somebody like got that over to him
and he was offended by that you know so
he hit me up and he was like man if you
don't want to go why are you going and
so it turned into a whole thing but I
still went you know and it just you know
and when I got there I didn't know what
to expect I didn't you know you know
what I mean it was just like you know I
I don't normally go to downtown I I just
had I didn't know what I was expecting
or how it was going to be but I just
want to tell you something skank Fest
was such a good time and it is such a
great comedy event
um and I mean that it it just like
from everything about it
first of all shout out to all like real
true comedy nerds man that's the people
that showed up to this it's like die
hard comedy fans they love podcasts they
love stand up they love the community
they know little ins and outs about it
and they they showed up in droves it was
thousands of people out there to to
watch and enjoy themselves and to
appreciate
the you know the comics and I felt it
everywhere I went
so this thing that they've created it's
great because one it was a great hang
for the comics so now I'm seeing a bunch
of comics that I don't normally get to
hang out with my my boys from New York
shout out to Godfrey who was there Dante
who was there some new guys I met uh you
know it was just you know just really
great time and you know we it's just
like a great like summer camp comic fans
we just hanging out but what made it
great is that the shows were great TJ
Miller uh uh Tim Dylan was there uh
um um who else was there uh Dan Soder
was there uh you know Lewis big J you
know Kim Condon like so many people were
there that you just go oh Ty Rivera
shout out to him too like you know you
see these people go oh wow we're all in
the same place so I showed up on the
Thursday and I got up in this like Rock
Club show standing room only and from
jump they were just so excited to like
see your comedy and be a part of it and
so like the fans were great the crowds
were great the shows were great and like
I said the comic hang was great just
being with the comics was great but like
to have that and have like attentive
crowds who just they don't care about
the sensitivity they wanted to hear raw
in your face comedy and they were all
about it and it just was man I'm just it
exceeded all expectations and even if I
had low expectations it overblown the
explosions to the point where I'm
talking about on my podcast I'm telling
people like yo even Comics out there yo
Comics if you have if you had a thing
where you were like I don't know about
skank Fest I totally get it it's called
skank Fest right I'm telling you it's
gonna be the time of your life it really
is a fun time and like if if I want to
compare to other festivals
there's other festivals man just like
this element of Industry that has to be
there like you know and then so there's
like a certain level of like pressure
and expectations that you feel like oh
more like I'm performing to get a deal
or like I have to impress people that
you shouldn't have to impress there's no
Gatekeepers here no Gatekeepers and if
they were there they were there as fans
and that's how you want it it was all
people that just love comedy
from all walks of life
from all over the country it wasn't even
like there was a lot of locals people
flew into Vegas just for skank Fest and
you felt that okay
so
again I I want to thank them for
inviting me even if we had like a little
weird little thing between Lewis and I
that we squashed completely uh I want to
tell like it was just great and so now I
gotta come out and give the message to
my comic friends I gotta tell everybody
who was like sort of squeamish about it
or didn't know what it what what's this
about or if they think it's going to be
this like abrasive New York septic tank
uh you know Ari shaffir and his his uh
uh uh um podcast kill Tony was there I
did Kill Tony again you know what I mean
it's that kind of stuff so there was
podcasts going on as well as great
comedy shows so all the comics that
think like I don't know what this is
about I'm telling you put your ego aside
and just think about like comedy fans
and this is a chance to actually be in
front of them and just feel the love
Robert Kelly was there like I I just you
know David tell was there Jim Norton
Richard Voss like all these great Comics
who were just like among the people and
I just I can't say enough how much I
enjoyed skank Fest and want to send some
love and some shout outs to
Louis Gomez and Big Jay oakerson and all
the people the people from The Stand in
New York and uh Rebecca from uh you know
Creek in the cave everybody involved in
it it was a fabulous time and I want to
thank you for for having me and I'm
telling you all it is completely worth
going next year so you know you should
you should uh try to go
you guys should try to go next year and
I'm going to be talking to my friends
you know Comics that don't normally go
to some to that I'm gonna be letting
them know no you should go you know it's
not about money it's not about it's
really just about being in front of
Comedy like real comedy fans and being
amongst your peers and just kind of
feeling that like Vibe or it makes you
feel like yeah you see the Brotherhood
and you're like damn look at us
anyways
that's it skank Fest y'all skank Fest
all right let's get into some stuff
that's been going on I wanted to talk
about uh I don't know if y'all heard but
um James Corden man he had like a
situation huh James Corden he like was
at this uh apparently he was at this
restaurant he was acting out you know
what I mean he was acting up
um it's a popular New York Eatery and
James Corden was an abusive customer
after his order was messed up Hey listen
I get this I complained about stuff my
damn self you know I have my moments
where I'm like you know what the hell's
going on and there's like a good side
and bad side to social media
um it could be used for like I say it
can be used for good or could you it
could be used for bad but you can't
decide and who could decide what's good
or bad even like podcasting is like
social media so even me even talking
about this and other people talking
about it it just brings some light on
people and their behavior and how they
should act or shouldn't act you know
what I mean and so this is like letting
you know like whoa you gotta be careful
even when you think about that Draymond
Green situation uh him punching Jordan
Poole at practice thinking this is a
closed practice and we're having like a
thing you never know somebody's
recording so it gives you pause you know
especially when you're in an image
business when you're in a business that
it is how people feel about you is
important because it leads to people
watching your show or paying for your
products or coming to your establishment
or you know turning the channel to your
show and and uh therefore that you know
and that leads to like advertising
dollars for you it's all connected so
then it gives you a moment of being like
yo maybe I need to not be acting out I
mean that's really what it is you know
so you know you got to ask yourself like
what what does it all mean like I say
man you know social media is a
double-edged sword there's good and
there's bad and it's not up to us to
decide what is good and what is bad you
know so you know sometimes people have a
moment man you know sometimes you like
you know I'm not gonna judge I don't
want to judge the guy like you know but
what happens is the perception is here's
a rich guy famous and and he was hitting
him with the do you know who I am vibe
that's the vibe do you know who you're
talking to Vibe and when that's being
recorded that you know it comes off the
way it comes off you know he he since
apologized I believe he's allowed back
into the restaurant there was two
separate incidences that you know he was
just like acting out you know what I
mean like yo man give me my food right
and I think we've all been there is it
fair that it was recorded and put out
there probably not but the consequences
of it are it is what it is and so it's
just like a cautionary tale for people
out there to be like yo
um be careful what you do what you say
you know
you never know what uh you never know
who's like I say who's recording and
where this is going to come out you know
I I don't know how I feel about it you
know I had some strong feelings about
this
um
that recording of the Draymond Green you
know
video of him punching the guy at
practice I don't think that should have
come out but it did so it is what it is
but I do have a problem with like
whatever people's intentions so that's I
guess that's really what I'm talking
about like what are your intentions when
you do this like a lot of times it's
just some clout chasing stuff man so
like there are a lot of times where
people like when they screenshot DMS and
and like that kind of stuff they just
trying to put that out what's their
intention dude are they really is there
intention really to like do some good or
is there intention to harm or to like
bring like look what I did I caught this
person whatever it is you never know
what people's intentions are regardless
of people's intentions when things get
out you have to sadly you have to answer
for that or in some cases it's something
like this like maybe like this like
let's say you know celebrities like this
coming to this guy's restaurant all the
time and they you know they treat the
staff a certain way and then this guy's
like well I don't have no recourse so
nothing I could say that you know
apparently the story James Corden was
saying like I'm going to write a
terrible Yelp review and look when
someone like that writes a Yelp review
that could be serious damage to your
business if people just Google and it
comes up James Corden says this
restaurant sucks so this guy took his
only opportunity to be like well we need
to go to social media with this so he
doesn't do that let's you know let's
beat him to the punch and so then now
he's out here probably not really
wanting to apologize probably really
feeling like yo the service sucked and
maybe it did like what if the service
really really sucked and so he acted out
but like with great power comes great
responsibility when you are like a
public figure as big as he is with a
late night talk show and you know he's
just in the public eye uh you know your
behavior whether whether you're going
through something or not is going to be
called into question when something like
this comes out you know what I mean so
it just it's it's crazy I will I am
going to get Rachel back on the show I
see people in the chat it's just like
today was just one of those days man
sometimes you have like I have to get it
set up and it is a thing with Rachel I
got to set it up because she got to get
ready and get dressed she can't just go
on the Fly she wants to know what we're
talking about so it is like a different
setup for that but I promise you in
coming weeks you will see the lovely Mrs
Griffin on the show so yeah I don't know
how you guys feel about it in the chat
or if you want to talk about it on the
on the comments what do you think about
social media the way it's uh but the way
it's being used it can be used as a
weapon man social media can be used as a
weapon against people and so my problem
only with it is it's like we don't know
what really happened like did this
really happen at the restaurant in this
way because they could be lying too man
you know it's like they can be lying
people could say whatever you want to
say like I saw something about somebody
came up to me was talking about like oh
I I don't pay my openers or something
it's not some crap some some dude like
some coward who like could have easily
hit me up or like would you ask me about
it went on something and is talking
about this it's like but when people say
that like then there's people out there
who believe it but they don't know the
whole context like
I don't I'm not big time I'm not doing
theaters I'm doing clubs and a lot of
times I'm not bringing that person I
don't know people I don't know you a lot
of times it's like the club itself has
booked the opener and they're paying
them
you know and so I'm just there as the
headliner on the weekend and these are
local people it's not up to me to take
care of somebody I don't even know that
I didn't even hire that I didn't even
get a say in who's there that's just how
that works sometimes but the perception
of it is when somebody just puts that
out like that just saying that but now
you have to answer for it so now some
you know somebody gonna put out
something oh Eric Griffin's cheap with
his and that's just not true that's just
not true you know so you know it it is
what it is you know you know what I'm
saying like what are you what are you
supposed to do
you know so I don't know
um
like I say you know you you know
sometimes some something comes out about
you and you just have to address it and
sometimes you don't even whatever people
think they're gonna think
you know that's why I think sometimes
it's unfair when allegations about
someone go out before they are verified
before there's like I didn't like our
true investigation just somebody's like
you know because the media is being used
in the same way too I don't think that's
fair I think it's unfair to people I
think it's like you know especially
because it has a a big impact it could
really it can really affect someone's
life you know and uh you know is it's
like you can't talk about covid even
using the word covid that all of a
sudden there's like fact checking and
then like there's a thing that comes on
your Instagram that's like oh uh you
know and if you say something or even
repost something that is like there's
some sort of system where they're like
oh we had to fact check this and you
know you know they put some kind of
disclaimer but they don't put
disclaimers when somebody says something
about someone else there's no fact
checking about what I'm talking about
was there any fact checking about this
James Corden thing no they just people
just put stuff out and then boom there's
no follow-up there's no nothing just
like let me put this out and see to get
my clout to get my whatever to get the
likes to get to to sell magazines and
newspapers to get clicks on your
podcasts and your Instagram and you know
without any recourse you know so I don't
know it's just it's a weird thing it's a
new world we're living in and I feel
like there's there there might need to
be like laws in place for this very
thing
that no you not like it's I feel like
we're coming to the point where it's
like no you can't just say whatever you
want about somebody
um
you know what I mean
no I know I understand I see somebody in
the chat and said it's true he admitted
it and apologized publicly what I'm
saying is it we don't know the the
context of what was happening he
probably was being a complete ass okay
but what I'm saying is there is a
situation where it wasn't like that it
could have been the waiter was having a
bad day and he said you know I don't
know if I've told you guys this story
about how a meter made completely lied
on me and they said whatever they they
said something that I had to go get a
lawyer it was a whole thing like people
can say whatever they want and once it
gets out you know he has to answer for
that so even if he wasn't like he it
could have been very mild but they could
have made it out to be more than it was
he could have been Justified of being
like I don't like this place I'm writing
a Yelp review you know what I mean he
could have easily you know what I'm
saying like it could have been you know
uh we don't know the level you know but
whatever level it was he has to come out
and say something something you know
what I mean like he got to come out and
be like hey this would happen so
hopefully it was resolved you know and
it's like now you have to just be more
cautious you and the public eye you got
to be cautious and I suggest that you do
that you know what I mean be freaking
cautious all right
um now a word from our sponsor where is
it better help
betterhelp.com
slash Griffin for the discount man guys
I'm all about therapy I think therapy is
important we exercise our bodies
to get better and I think we should
exercise our minds in this same way
maintenance therapy is just maintenance
on the brain on the mood on the emotions
to make sure you know it can be tough to
train your brain to stay in problem
solving mode when faced with a challenge
in life
but when you learn how to find your own
Solutions there's no better feeling and
that's what I think therapy helps you do
it helps you organize your thoughts
helps you recognize patterns with a
professional who gets that sometimes you
need that third party that second you
know another a set of eyes and ears and
experience and knowledge to help you
understand what's going on with you so
you can you in a way that you never saw
it before and I think that that's really
important and better help is all about
that if you're thinking of giving
therapy a try better help is a great
option it's convenient accessible
affordable and entirely online get
matched with the therapist after filling
out a brief survey and switch therapists
at any time and that's important too
because sometimes you feel like you get
stuck in this like relationship and now
you can like if you're not feeling it
find the new match when you want to be a
better Problem Solver therapy can get
you there visit betterhelp.com Griffin
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash Griffin
okay y'all
um what's next here uh yeah let's get to
this
um so I don't know if you guys saw this
freaking thing man did you guys see this
bear attack man
this sucker is crazy Z dude copyright
2022 bear attacks climber all right
um so this guy's just in Japan
oh man
uh you can't I'm not even playing the
sound but he is going bananas
this bear you know what I mean like this
is just like like what's your thoughts
when you see this
like personally like at this point right
here you're just kind of chilling you
look up right
like you look up and you see
a bear
coming at you
you know what I mean
[Laughter]
[Music]
like
the bear is all up in the GoPro
but luckily he's on this cliff
and the guy is screaming and hollering
dude
laughs
this is when The High Ground works
now here here's the thing
thankfully for this guy
this was a baby bear
and I personally think the bear was just
messing around
I think like you know Bears I think the
bear was just kind of like oh what's
this what up dude oh what you doing you
climbing come here man Papa pow and he
was just messing around lunged at him
boom because if this was a mama grizzly
bear and that's her bear cub that's out
here this would not have gone this way
that bear would like with those big old
claws would have sliced him right away
and that just do to be dead and it's
just like how frightening is this
you know what would you want to deal
with
this bear this baby bear on a hill like
this or you're a waiter and James Corden
is going off
I should I should make that let me make
that a poll real quick on uh
on the on the chat right now
uh uh let's say okay which which one
baby bear
or uh wait on James
Cordon yeah if you're listening right
now on Apple Apple or Spotify or
wherever you get your podcast sometimes
you gotta listen to me live on Tuesdays
turn on the notifications on YouTube and
you will get to
watch me live and be inside the um you
know the chat as I do this you know
stuff but anyways but thanks for
listening always I appreciate you guys
and everybody please like leave a
comment on the Apple podcast if you
leave a comment there it actually helps
me out with the algorithm if you leave a
comment and leave a you know a good
review and and hit the Stars you know
that helps out
so I know what you're saying somebody
asked is that a baby bear I mean yeah in
comparison to like a real big like a
real full-size bear I mean look at it I
mean look at this you know let's just
look at it right here you know like this
is not like the bit like like you could
just see right here that this bear it
really does look like a like a teenager
you know
you know what I mean and you could see
oh my God I just I don't even know this
is like that one remember when the
cougar was stalking the guy remember
when a cougar was stalking the guy and I
don't mean an older woman
oh you got to hear the guy Scream dude
the guy I mean it's just like he's
terrified he's like I mean like what
like what else do you do in this
situation a freaking big ass bear is
coming at you
I I just I don't know
[Laughter]
I've never really dealt with like a wild
animal like this before I would love to
hear people's stories anybody had like a
situation like this like a bobcat in the
yard there was that other one where the
woman was like had her kid she had her
kid you know on her like she was holding
onto a baby or a kid and her there was a
bear in her backyard bigger than this
one and the bear was on the on the uh on
a thing and the dog was like barking and
she saw the bear she was thinking about
her dog and she goes over and pushes the
bear off of the of the uh
um the fence
did y'all see that one
pushes the bear off the fence and then
uh you know just kind of like grabs her
dog like come on like I guess when you
in that mode
um
when you're on that mode like what like
what do you even do you know oh I got it
right here y'all this is great
you know so let's let's get this
oh I have to like I you like you guys
don't hear this but I have to watch this
La this uh
this uh ad
here we go hold up so this is what's
happening this is this video right here
I don't know if you guys saw this back
in there but this is what I'm saying
he's talking about dealing with a bear a
bear y'all
[Laughter]
look at this big ass beer
there's like a oh and it's a mama bear
too with some Cubs like those are like
real baby cubs
wow
and then the bear is like get away from
my
oh my God
like why is this
like why is that other thing on the
screen what is that I don't want to see
that
there we go
I mean she's straight up oh I hate that
she straight up pushes this this is a
terrible version of it anyways you saw
it
I mean imagine
you know you see your a bear swiping at
your dogs
you know what I mean and then you just
some lady comes out just pushes the bear
I just like I don't even know
if I wanna like what do you think about
living at a place where a bear could
just be in your backyard
like this is one of these things where
like this bear like first of all the
Bear Just is strolling up with his kids
you know
I guess you know what I think about
you know you know it just it doesn't
funny like wait let me see if I can get
a better a better version of it this is
like
I guess this is what we do
you know I guess this is like a teen or
something I guess I guess we're kind of
doing the same thing man we're doing the
same thing when we go to like
Yellowstone Park with our kids
you know we go to Yellowstone Park with
our kids and we're just walking with our
kids you know because that's what this
is
we're walking with our kids
right and then like some bear comes
you know what I mean and then like our
dog or something is there this dog's
like what are you doing dogs like get
away from our thing
you know and then the little dog and the
mom's like get off my
wow
and she grabs the dog y'all I'm just
telling you right now
I guess I'm not a dog owner so I don't
want to say I would never do this but
when I see this I go I don't think I'd
ever do this
it's like I don't know do people live in
an area where just dogs just be out
there like that
who who you know that that's that's
crazy to me I just I see that and I just
go I don't know if it might be time to
move
you know what I mean like I I'm moving
y'all I'm moving
all right let's go into some uh reviews
man let's go into some reviews of some
stuff
uh She-Hulk I can't wait to watch the I
think I think I already I haven't seen
the series finale oh the the season
finale yet but uh or was that the season
finale I don't even know if I talked
about it or not but I think she Hawk
finally is heating up can't wait to
watch the the final it's good um and I'm
watching some other shows that I want to
talk about too Interview with a Vampire
is really good
y'all got to check that out interviewed
a vampire dope
really like what they're doing uh but
she Hulk yeah I think that there's like
a few episodes of she-hawk where I'm
just kind of like
I don't think it was unnecessary that
like the the stuff with the other suit
of the villain girl and trademarking
She-Hulk all that storyline was garbanzo
beans
this the storyline of like somebody
trying to steal she-hawks blood and and
then Daredevil showed up who's also a
lawyer so it made sense uh you know all
that was great I enjoyed that so I
enjoyed the first two episodes and I
enjoyed the last three episodes I think
that that's oh that's what the show
should have been you know uh but it's
different I really liked it and the girl
that plays She-Hulk she's like a really
great actress you know what I mean
uh I like how you guys would rather deal
with the baby bear than
wait on James Corden
but I knew you guys would do that
because you're trying to be funny but I
get it it's cute
um yeah so I'm looking forward to
watching the last episode
of of she-hawk
um so we'll see
you know what I mean we will see uh but
that's really let's not even get into
that one let's actually get into like
the one I really want to talk about and
that's uh House of dragons House of the
Dragon man House of the Dragon
is really heating up I don't I don't
really like the time Jump
I don't like to time Jump uh but I guess
they
I guess they're doing this to like as
this first season is like hey let's show
you where it started kind of get an idea
of what's happening with the characters
and this is how you know it works and
and what they're sort of their Origins
and then here we are now with it you
know I think all the actors and
actresses from the first parts of the
series
have uh have done pretty good you know
uh and yes I do respond to comments but
don't be a needy [ __ ] okay
um
yeah so I thought it was like a little
slow I don't think there's enough
violence of the time that it like of
this sort of era of
um genre that it's representing this
sort of medieval
you know Intrigue killing and you know
uh women get treated a certain way and
there's dragons and you know it's like a
brutality that's going on and there's a
lot of politics and I I think that you
know they've kind of toned down the sex
and the violence I think from because of
the time we're living in right now and I
think some of the backlash they got from
the first season of the first series you
know uh Game of Thrones because if you
know first few seasons of Game of
Thrones man there was just a lot of
raping and pillaging going on and it was
like but it felt accurate for the times
but it doesn't necessarily mean you have
to show it but at the same time you want
to know that that's going on like
there's still a way to do it where you
don't necessarily have to show it we
don't need to see it but we need to know
what's happening so we can get a sense
of like this is the world we live in and
they kind of doing that in this show
because the dude that's playing the the
young Egon he's like terrible you know
he's just like uh you know he he raping
housemaids and he got kids all over the
city he got kids all over uh uh what's
the name of the the main city
um
you know what I mean so and and so so we
cut to this point now where like you
know King visarius I think I'm saying it
right you know he's been ravaged by
whatever disease that is I think it's
cancer it looks like cancer because I've
actually seen someone like that they
didn't know what cancer was at the time
you know but that's what cancer does
I've seen like a few sort of homeless
people with their face eaten away
because they got cancer and they don't
got the resources to go to the doctor
it's really sad but it's like that's
what it looks like you know and so he's
got this cancer it's eaten away at him
and you know but he's just like trying
to like bring his family together and
it's just not going well you know what I
mean like his daughter is not having sex
with his black her black blonde-haired
husband only reason why I bring up that
he's black with blonde hair is his kids
ain't black with blonde hair
these kids that she's supposedly having
with him because she was having sex with
the with the other dude the soldier but
you could tell she has a lot of love for
the guy though that they made a pact a
long time ago that let's just do our
duty let's do our duty but we you do
what you want to do I'll do what I want
to do and then the other guy who she was
having sex with he didn't want to be he
didn't want to be a side piece right he
didn't want to be a side piece and I
think he's still in love with her and
mad about that so he sort of befriended
to Queen so they got they mad because
her kids got passed over because she was
named the air even though he had a son
with her so there's all this like sort
of in political entry going on because
she want her and her father want her son
to be the king but the king loves his
daughter and wants her to be the heir so
they got the two families you know
fighting with each other and then like
the black dude uh from a house Valerian
or whatever it is you know he he can't
hack his he obviously shooting blanks
they tried it didn't happen and he's gay
he want to be with this dude and then
the other dude who's in love with the
princess you know he kills the the lover
of the gay dude and so he you know what
I mean it's like all that was the most
brutal that was like real brutal that
dude he needs to be put down he don't
kill two people needlessly already
all right so anyways so you have that
right and then the queen's kids they
some little they some bastards you know
like I'm not bastards like real bastards
they just not they they tough they not
good dudes like the one son the oldest
son who's the heir who they want to be
air like I said he's out here raping bed
maids and you know the the chamber maids
and stuff like that and then the queen
has to come in and clean it up you know
and then he out in the streets you know
he got a bunch of kids out in the
streets uh you know and then the other
son who got his eye cut off cut out by
the the the princesses kids he is you
know
I don't I don't know if he's evil but
you can tell he got a chip on his
shoulder he done stole the dragon from
the black family you know because the
mother killed herself because she was
she she couldn't
she couldn't give birth and so she went
out to her Dragon it was like kill me
you know set me on fire dragon so that
was crazy so her Dragon was unclaimed
and then the prince goes out oh spoiler
by the way
[Laughter]
sorry
you know what I mean so
you know anyways so the guy he goes he's
fighting with he's fighting with his
nephew's cousins the the the you know
his sister's kids you know who are his
nephews even though they're the same age
you know because he knows they not
really
the the the the sons of the black dude
so there's there's tension there and
then they don't want they're thinking
too that if their mother if the princess
dies that one of these like bastard kids
is gonna end up being King so they got
some chips on their shoulder with that
and then the one kid he couldn't get a
dragon so then like you know he went out
stole this dragon and that caused the
fight that's why he got stabbed now they
did a time Jump and the time Jump is
where now he's a little bit older now
but he should actually be king you know
what I mean he reads philosophy and he's
a warrior you know he actually beat the
the the the the the you know the the
captain of the Guard guy you know he
like beat him in at practice and so he's
like equipped you know so it's like it's
so interesting that that the bloodline
stuff is more important than ability in
and uh worthiness you know
so
um that's that's and I what I'm saying I
say all that to say that I I think that
they they're setting up
some good stuff for season two so the
final episode is coming up on Sunday and
we find out what happens because it was
a great like I don't know if you you
know it was a great like you know the
one you know the wife of the other black
dude the heads of the Valerian house you
know that he went off to battle he'd
been gone six years and now she's like
trying to figure out who's gonna be the
heir of this family now because she was
supposed to be the queen of the you know
the main Queen and then that got taken
away from her because she's a woman so
you know all that stuff is going on so
it's interesting and then she like does
this Great rescue Escape you know
because
oh because the main thing too is that
the Queen the main Queen
she misunderstood the King on his
deathbed like there's some prophecy and
I think the prophecy is about you know
what we know is House of dragons I mean
not House of dragons of Game of Thrones
so you know so he in his like delirium
of like dying is talking about you know
that prophecy and the queen
misunderstands him and thinks he's
saying
that he wants his son on the throne but
they were going to find a way to usurp
the the princess anyway and so that's
why a big battle is coming in the final
episode so we'll see man we will see but
I really like what's happening and I do
think they're setting up a great season
too where I don't think there's gonna be
some time jumps but they do have you
know 172 years to work with because
that's what they originally said was it
172 or was it 372 years whatever how
many years it is
they have a lot of time where they could
be like all right here's another a whole
new if they wanted to they could be like
here's a whole new set of targaryens
that we're gonna deal with
and that's and that's also a a tricky
way to not pay people
I'm just talking about some inside actor
stuff because you know once people get
to like the third season of something
they that's when you know money starts
to you know so that's a way of being
like we don't want to get these we don't
want these actors and actresses to get
too famous where we're gonna have to
start paying them so what we'll do is
we'll just time Jump time Jump 50 years
and here's a whole new cast I mean they
might do that who knows so we'll see how
that goes but uh it's good
I like it it's good if you haven't
watched it you should watch it
um
all right so check that out guys
all right let's uh let's uh do just
finish up with this other story that I I
wanted to get into
um
oh let me get back to my other
background
yeah I've seen a one-man show doing it
all by myself all right uh let's get
back to so guys I don't know if you know
Oscar Meyer like this is this is crazy
but Oscar Meyer unveils hot dog flavored
pops a popsicle and they're calling it
cold dogs
what
cold dogs yeah cold dogs this is one of
these situations where
just because you can
doesn't mean you should
not not everything needs to be made into
a flavor for a popsicle ice cream or
whatever that is
that sounds disgusting
you hear what I'm saying that sounds
absolutely disgusting I don't even know
what to say about that
but get out of here man get out of here
with that dot that with that nonsense
you know what I mean like who's gonna
try this
like you know why would you try this
why I have no idea
like what's the next flavor gonna be
like I don't want like those two things
don't seem to be
a popsicle like I don't want a breakfast
popsicle I don't want like a popsicle to
taste like eggs and bacon I don't want
cold ass eggs and bacon like that
doesn't even make any sense to me uh
right I mean I don't know what what you
guys think of this but that you know
what are you what are you guys thinking
you know like does that sound like
something that you find delicious like
popcorn yeah peanut like maybe peanut
butter and jelly could be a popsicle
maybe you know but
a hot dog and then it's got a picture of
mustard like what are you like what are
we talking about y'all what what are we
talking about
like I'm sorry
that is not something that anybody
should want to freaking
um
you know
freaking half
oof you know I don't know
I'm trying to all right that that's just
I don't know that's all I want to talk
about and and I know I was I did say I
was going to talk about the NBA
um you know what I mean
all this time I was doing this the NBA
is starting today
and I am excited about the NBA but I
want to do a proper NBA preview probably
next week after a week of games have
gone by and let's see where we're at can
the Warriors repeat I don't know is
LeBron James age finally going to catch
up to him like Tom Brady's age is
catching up to him and all this offs
court stuff is Russell Westbrook gonna
get traded are they going to be able to
work together are the Suns gonna get
back to being a a top-notch team
Philadelphia is James Harden gonna look
good how are the Celtics going to deal
with not having their coach after going
to the championship is this going to be
Milwaukee's year to get back to the
championship and now that Denver has
Jamal Murray back and that other dude
that got hurt that are they a contender
in the west now that they have that the
the MVP of the league you know uh of the
regular season joke The Joker are they
gonna make themselves as the best team
in the west we shall will see I'm going
to be talking about the NBA a lot and
I'm also going to be talking about the
NFL as the you know as we finish off
as we finish off the NFL season so I you
know so look out for that
um that's that's coming your way also
guys that's coming your way also all
right so
um
let me see I got some uh Beats from my
guy uh let's see
this is another some more Beats from my
guy Chris you for our rap recap I want
to thank everybody for being here
once again
we finished the show I tell a friend
I don't pretend coming at you
NBA season it's about to start don't
look down I'm about to fart
in my car
[Music]
was legit
I hope they don't quit
everything is the [ __ ] huh
[Music]
might as well have bull frogs
that's me I'm boss Hall
rap recap
so you know where it's at
[Music]
like that
it's never Slack
all right y'all
that's such dad [ __ ]
anyways thanks for being here guys and
uh shout out to Chris you for that beat
and anybody want to make a beat send it
to me and uh you know you it might make
the end of the show uh but you guys have
been great thanks for watching riffing
with Griffin and I will see you
next week let's say that beat again yeah
thank you y'all see you later
[Music]